♪ Stroke my chin real
slow when I'm lying ♪
♪ And I was laughing
super hard ♪
♪ As Darnell was dying ♪
- The name of the album is
"I killed Darnell Simmons!"
- It's a concept I wrote.
- A concept?!
That's a picture of you,
a picture of you and behind
you is Darnell Simmons' body!
(tense music)
- Coincidence.
(cameras clicking)
(dramatic music)
- It's a weird one.
Nothing out of place,
no murder weapon.
- And no motive.
They're just a couple
lying dead in their bed.
- The proof is always
out there, detectives.
You just have to know
where to find the pudding.
- Excuse me, sir,
you can't be here.
This is the crime scene.
- Stay calm.
It's okay.
He's the greatest sex crime
investigator in history.
If it isn't Detective
Chuck Vaughn.
- Detective Sally Ferguson.
- [Sally] We could
use a genius right now
- Thomas Samwell.
- (sighs) What have
we got, Samwell?
- Well, Vaughn, we've got
ourselves a hard case here.
All we've got is--
- Two bodies, both dead,
naked, one man, one
woman in the bed.
Two scented candles
by the nightstand.
- How did you--
- Shh.
- No sign of forced entry.
(dramatic music)
He loved the way they smelled.
He wanted to cross the threshold
the way they had on
their wedding day.
(sighs) You dirty dog.
He would've experienced
that pleasure right here.
(pants unzipping)
(Chuck moaning)
(pants zipping)
Anniversary.
The couple was
together for a while,
wanted to spice things up.
Check the date on
the photograph.
- (sighs) Vaughn's right.
Today was their 15th
wedding anniversary.
This is huge.
- And what the (beeps) was that?
You just pulled your dick out
and started jerking
off at the crime scene!
- Samwell, he's
the best there is.
By putting himself in the
perpetrator's mindset,
he's able to solve
crimes that involve sex.
Bag this up.
- Some call it a blessing.
It's more like a curse.
- Is that what it feels like?
(dramatic music)
- Threesome.
(gasping) You wanted to
see them, didn't you?
You wanted to watch.
25 feet from the bedroom,
across from the kitchen.
(gasping) You didn't want to
see their flesh yet, did you?
No, he stood right here.
(pants unzipping)
(Chuck moaning)
- [Samwell] Oh, come on.
- (sighs) Role play gone wrong.
(pants zipping)
Check the logs.
(metal clattering)
- Hey.
We've got a bloody fire poker.
We've got our murder weapon.
- Um, why do your revelations
require masturbation?
- Why do kittens require milk?
- No, not the same thing.
- Hey, hey.
He's the most brilliant
goddamn detective I know.
Put your ego aside and
give Vaughn his space.
- My ego?!
We've got Captain Pudpuller
flinging his fluids all
over the crime scene!
- Wait.
(dramatic music)
He knew them.
Hey, they were close,
so close, too close.
He, he, I think
he knew the house.
(gasping) Why?
Oh, what did you want,
you sick bastard?
You wanted to see
what he saw every day.
Only closer, closer.
He was close to home.
(Chuck moaning)
(dramatic music continues)
There's our man.
- [Sally] All right,
let's go get him go.
Go, go!
- Vaughn, that was amazing.
I'm sorry that I doubted you.
Your methods are unorthodox,
but I cannot argue
with your results.
(pants zipping)
- No hard feelings.
- Uh, no, hope.
Not gonna do that.
- Yeah.
(dramatic music)
- Give yourself up, Carlo.
- Why would I do
that, Detective?
When I have the upper hand?
(Carlo chuckling)
- Give yourself up, Carlo.
- [Carlo] I'm right here,
Detective (giggles).
(Detective gasping)
Or am I over here, Detective?
(dramatic music intensifies)
Or here?
- Oh, you sick son of a bitch!
Where the hell are you?!
(Detective shouts)
(Carlo laughing)
Ha!
You son of a bitch, come out!
- Does my ass look
big in this jumpsuit?
- Enough with the games, Carlo.
- The games are just
beginning, Detective (laughs).
Mirror, mirror on the wall.
(laughs) Who is the
fairest of them all?
- Don't move.
You are under arrest for
the murder of Mary Dealey,
Meg Foster, and one
Detective Mason Jimenez.
Now where's the girl?
- Oh, Detective.
You assume it's the real me
standing in front of you,
but maybe that's just
what I want you to think.
When in reality, the real
me is safe in a hiding spuh.
- Okay, that's the
real you, all right.
- Or maybe I'm over here--
- No, no you're not over there.
Carlo, I'm only gonna
ask you one more time.
Where is the girl?
- Go ahead and shoot, Detective.
(chuckles) I mean,
what do I care
if you get seven
years bad, okay,
you know it's not safe to
keep a gun cocked like that,
even if you are just
pointing it at a mirror.
- Turn around and put
your hands on your head.
- Now for that, you really are
going to have to
find the real me.
- Oh my God, are you kidding me?
(gun firing)
(Carlo squeaks)
Carlo, what?
- Why would you shoot a mirror?
- Carlo, it's you!
I'm holding your lapel.
Now you're done, it's over.
- You're gonna cut your
hand on that broken mirror.
(gun cocks)
- Where is she?
- Just say it, dude.
- Say what?
- Say you don't
know whether or not
this is the real me or just
a reflection in a mirror.
- [Detective] Really?
- I'll tell you where she is.
- Okay.
I don't know whether
the you I'm holding onto
is really you--
- Or the reflection--
- Or, or a reflection
in the mirror.
- All there is to it.
She's under the floorboards
by the entrance.
Oh, God (moans)
I win, Detective.
Oh, I told you, but I mean
the mirror told you,
but what you know.
Oh (beeps).
(dramatic music)
(door slams)
- First things first.
I do not care that you are a
multi-platinum selling rapper,
Gun Rack, what I care
about is that I 100% know
that you murdered
Darnell Simmons,
so you better start talking.
- Yeah, but you
ain't got nothin'.
- Okay (chuckles),
you know, I'm actually, I'm
very glad that you said that
because, respectfully,
I beg to differ.
♪ I killed Darnell, yeah
I shot him with my nine ♪
♪ I shot him nine times ♪
♪ Don Pierre, I'm on the dime ♪
♪ And by the way, it
was November 9th ♪
(dramatic music)
- There don't mean nothin'.
I got a vivid imagination.
(Detective scoffs)
I couldn't have shot Darnell.
I was at my cousin's
birthday party,
Red Lobster, November 9th.
- At, at Red Lobster?
- Mm-hm.
- Geez, I gotta
tell you, Gun Rack,
I, I find that really
hard to believe.
♪ I got an alibi,
birthday, Red Lobster ♪
♪ When in reality, I shot
Darnell like a mobster ♪
♪ It's a lie anyone
could tell this ♪
♪ If you know about my
allergy to all shellfish ♪
- Just confess, Gun Rack.
- I confess that shellfish
is the only thing that
rhymes with tell this
It's just words, Detective.
Nouns, adjectives that just
happen to be in a dope order,
but you ain't got no proof.
♪ Shot up Darnell
with a long ass gun ♪
♪ And tossed into the aquarium ♪
(bag crunches)
- I have no idea
what that object is.
(dramatic music)
- I don't--
- If I had to identify
it, I would call it
a gun of the long ass variety.
Some seaweed in there too.
Look, Detective.
I hate to break it to
you, I ain't kill nobody.
- But...
♪ Stroke my chin real
slow when I'm lyin' ♪
♪ And I was laughin' super
hard as Darnell was dyin' ♪
- The name of the album is
"I Killed Darnell Simmons!"
- It's a concept I wrote.
- A concept?!
That's a picture of
you, a picture of you
and behind you is
Darnell Simmons' body!
- Coincidence.
- You're going away for a
long time, you understand?!
You're gonna confess if it's
the last thing you ever do!
You hear me, Gun Rack,
I'll beat it out of you!
(man shouts)
- (sighs) He's free to go.
(dramatic music)
- What? No, no, no, no, no.
We have everything we need.
- No, it was
Simmons' girlfriend.
She just confessed
to the whole thing.
Infidelity, crime of passion.
Let's go, Mr. Rack.
♪ Bonus track, bonus track ♪
♪ I got a ride or die bitch ♪
♪ I think you get the gist ♪
♪ And when you let me out,
I'm gonna blow a little kiss ♪
♪ This is my confession,
admissible in court ♪
♪ I killed Darnell
Simmons for sport ♪
♪ That's right, I'm a murderer ♪
♪ Come get me, come down
the hall you can't get me ♪
♪ Okay, okay, you got me ♪
♪ Damn, nigga, damn,
chill, ow, ow ♪
(crickets chirping)
(door knocking)
- Sue, oh my goodness!
Oh my goodness, how
are you doing, girl?
- Oh, you know, I
was on my way home
and was in the area, just
wanted to come say hello.
That's it, that is all.
Have a nice night.
- Sue, where you going, girl?
You can't leave
without coming inside!
- Oh no, I wouldn't
wanna be an intrusion.
I just wanted to
say hello, goodbye.
- Okay, now, Sue,
there is a seat
in this house with
your name on it, girl.
- No, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no.
I can't, I didn't have
money for the bus.
I'm a mess from
the 50 mile walk.
- Now, why must ya be
so difficult, girl?
- You're right, I am
being difficult, aren't I?
Your life is better
without me coming in.
Trust me.
So there I go.
- Okay, girl, listen.
Everything is all right,
man, we're good friends.
- Yes.
- All right.
- Of course.
- And you know
you can smell that, girl.
You know you smell it, girl.
- What's that smell?
- You know you're smelling
the fried dumplings,
the aki, and the
salt fish, girl.
Now what's come over you?
- I shoulda called,
I shoulda called.
- That's it, Sue!
I'm formally inviting
you into my home.
Now come inside!
(dramatic music)
(door slams)
(blood gushing)
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh, I want it, but
I don't need it ♪